[Music]
the villain kids in descendants too are
super edgy and tough but sometimes they
can be downright goofy we tracked down
some of the funniest bloopers
behind-the-scenes moments and wacky
interviews from the cast of descendants
- just for you guys you're not going to
want to miss the last one we are still
laughing about it if you're into
descendants - like we are subscribe to
the things channel to be the first to
see our new videos and click the like
button if you love descendants - as much
as we do
clumsy cast with all the dance
choreography in the films you would
think that the cast of descendants too
would be super graceful and balance
right think again we found a couple of
pretty clumsy moments in the blooper
reel that had the crew cracking up the
first one we found was when mom was
making her grand entrance on to you
mister she's supposed to look tough and
in control but instead she slips and
almost eats it right next to the pirate
swords dove Cameron realizes that she
ruined - the take and says alright we're
going back she turns around and walks
right back out we've all been there dove
then there was a time when Evie was in
the villain kids hideout on the Isle she
runs up to the end of their homemade two
megaphone and is supposed to call mouths
name but when Sofia Carson hit her mark
she hit something else - she
accidentally bonked her face on the edge
of the megaphone she kept going not
missing the beat but the crew started
cracking up Sofia laughed it off - even
uma had a clumsy moment in an interview
Chyna and McClain said she tripped when
she was dancing on the table for her big
number
what's my name whoops catch magic mirror
on the wall who's the blue proced one of
all Evie is sophisticated smart and
fashionable with all that going for her
it's not surprising that she might have
a small shortcoming once in a while for
instance her catching skills seem to be
a bit off there's a great blooper we
found when Evie is on umas pirate ship
the villain kids are about to have the
epic battle with uma and her crew the
situation is tense and Evie dove Jay and
Carlos need to look tough and
intimidating they have to defeat Yuma's
pirate crew if they are going to have a
shot at rescuing Ben and getting back to
our Don but there's a part where Evie is
supposed to catch a sword and
she misses she must've missed the catch
more than once because we watched the
final fight scene and there is no part
where Eevee catches the sword our guess
is that they changed it to accommodate
Sophia's lack of catching ability
don't worry Sofia you can always fall
back on your singing dancing acting
fashion designing and sword fighting
talents no one can do it all even if you
are the daughter of the Evil Queen
mouths wigs name let's face it dove
Cameron and that purple wig have been
through a lot together from the opening
number wicked when she dances with
poisoned apples and possessed the
students and parents of auradon prep so
when she gets reunited with her polished
purple locks at Dizzee salon curl up and
die and there was never a purple hair
out of place when mouths arm-wrestled
uma and then had a sword fight on umas
pirate ship her purple side braid was
gorgeous at the beginning of the
cotillion and even better when it formed
into purple waves after her epic dragon
battle against whom as octopus it's only
natural that dove would name her wig
what she did in this behind-the-scenes
video in the video she is in the makeup
trailer saying goodbyes the wig with
which she had been through so much one
of the makeup artists recommended
calling the wig mister mob dove laughs
and says goodbye to mr. mob at least she
won't have to part with it for too long
she put it on for the descendants three
teaser so there's a good chance that
Duff and mr. mob will be reunited for
the filming of the third film pranks we
found out that the director of The
Descendants movies Kimmie Ortega is
quite a prankster in an interview with
parade comm Kenny talked about some
pranks he has pulled on the cast's from
both the first and second descendants
films he said a couple of times the kids
worked really really hard for weeks on a
number and then he would come in and he
would look at it he said he would have a
real straight face and just say no what
it's just not good enough then he would
tell them that they should probably just
start all over again from scratch he
said it really pulled the rug out from
under the cast for a moment then he
would laugh it off and say gotcha and
that's not the only time he pulled a
prank in the first dissonance film he
had the cast run up on dub Cameron
during her big emotional number in the
woods and surprised her she said she was
singing the song if only when she heard
footsteps and thought zombies were
coming to attack her but then she turned
around and discovered it was Sophie
Kameron boo-boo and Mitch to say she was
relieved would be an understatement good
one Kenny dropping the Apple the opening
number in descendants 2 is totally
amazeballs dove Cameron said that her
favorite part about the number is
dancing with all these zombified auradon
prep kids as they dance and sing about
the ways to be wicked that number was
pretty complex according to King Ortega
it took place over two or three weeks of
their shooting schedule that's a lot of
work for a three and a half minute song
can he said they shot the number in
pieces our Don was not all in one
location they had the exterior of the
castle the interior of the castle the
hallways locker areas and then the
garden area and the front of the school
he said they would do it in chunks and
rehearsed before shooting each piece but
even with all that rehearsal bloopers
still happened Cameron Boyce was
supposed to juggle apples in front of
Bell and King beasts before giving them
the apples and dancing away but juggling
and singing and dancing isn't as easy as
it may look there's a blooper of him
dropping the apples during one of the
tapes if you watched the final edit
you'll see that Cameron has to sing
while juggling and then toss the apples
to the king and queen yep that looks
hard The Incredible Hulk and the Carlos
clones when he watched dissonance 2 it
almost seems like the cast has
superpowers they are so good especially
booboo Stewart he is handled by the cast
has the best sword fighter he does tons
of flips and acrobatics in the movie the
guy is just awesome but he left the fans
in on a little secret during the
interview apparently all of his clothes
keep ripping he said in the first week
two jackets rips then he said his fluffs
ripped and his fingers were coming out
of them then he said he was bursting out
of his shoes and his socks on both feet
he was dancing in with him so hard he
Incredible Hulk right out of his costume
in the same interview Cameron Boyce
shared that since he was a minor during
the shooting of the film he had to have
about four or five doubles he said he
had a stunt double a dance double and he
had to picture doubles Sofia Carson said
that more than once they would go up to
Cameron from behind to say hey and then
realize it wasn't him they had a bunch
of Carlos clones walking around the set
wearing the same wig trippy dove Cameron
can't drive a Vespa you know how in the
movie Finn gives mal a purple Vespa as a
present and she totally is over the moon
excited about it then she knew
that purple Vespa to escape the
pressures of royalty and volts back to
the Isle where she feels she belongs it
totally looks like she's driving that
Vespa right well dove Cameron revealed
that any time the audience sees her on
that Vespa it's a lie they used a double
to do the scenes where mal is driving
the Vespa Deb said that anytime you see
her on the Vespa she was barely able to
keep it upright
she said her feet didn't touch the
ground she remembers being perched on an
awkwardly to do the scenes
Cameron boy said one of his favorite
moments of filming was seeing da bond
the Vespa in front of a green screen
with these dudes crouched out of frame
spinning the wheels and rocking the
scooter back and forth with one hand on
the basket at the back so let's go down
dub Cameron's list of credentials
singing check dancing check acting check
driving a Vespa fail
why does she don't have to have it all
we still love you dub evil antenna we
all know that Maleficent is rotten to
the core and totally wicked but did you
also know that she can be used as an
antenna neither did we until we found
out this funny outtake okay we're just
gonna preface this by saying we know
that nas mom is a lizard and dissonance
2/4 we missed her so much we thought we
would include her in our favorite
outtakes even if this one is from the
first descendants movie remember that
scene when fairy godmother facilitates a
video call for the villain kids from
their parents who were still trapped on
the Isle
well they captured comedy gold footage
of the villains trying to figure out how
to use the video calling system in this
scene that mostly wound up on the
cutting room floor the Evil Queen puts
aluminum foil on Maleficent horns and
tries to use them as Nintendo then Jafar
tries raising her hands up to get a good
signal you see kids this is what folks
had to do in the old school analog TV
watching days well - the horns anyway
it's really hilarious if you have the
DVD check out the bonus features to
sneak a peek at it deleted song and
scenes along with the bloopers and funny
outtakes there are some deleted scenes
worth talking about
first there's the deleted song that
didn't make the final cut of descendants
- it was supposed to come after mal and
Jay have a heartfelt talk in the grassy
garden outside of art on prep Jay
reassures mal and tells her to come to
the cotillion that night after Jay
leaves mousing the song from the first
film you know the one called if only
for some reason the filmmakers cut the
song bummer speaking of cutscenes did
you know that the other two characters
were filmed saying the final phrase of
the movie yep little dizzy Jermaine also
said the famous line you didn't think
this was the end of the story did you
then she giggles and jumped up and down
with her invitation to our don prep in
her hands
they also filmed harry hook saying the
last line and this deleted scene he's
doctors up to the camera and says the
line then he caresses his cheek with the
hook and chuckles before he glides out
of the frame we loved them both but it's
clear why they chose uma to deliver the
final line big inside secret the cast
has become incredibly close during the
filming of descendants and descendants
too they laughed a lot they cried they
pranked each other they ripped out of
their own clothing butts a few Carson
and the cast shared a special insider
secret that we can't stop smiling about
she revealed that Kenny taught the cast
a chance before they would film each
musical number she said all the dancers
and all the casts would huddle up into a
big circle and do this chant that has a
lot of boom Shakalaka isn't it Chyna and
McClain said it helped the whole cast
get hyped before a scene we're going to
go out on a limb and say it totally
worked the numbers are high energy the
dance routines are masterful and fun and
all the villain kids add their own flair
of sass and passion to each musical
number that they do so what's your
favorite musical number how about your
favorite blooper or behind-the-scenes
moment leave your answer in the comments
we know one thing we can't wait for
descendants three to come out don't you
guys agree and that's it for the 10
funniest bloopers you never saw from
descendants two we hope you had as much
fun as we did see you next time on the
things
[Music]